le port du masque de nouveau obligatoire
en ce jour de rentrée scolaire dans les
39 départements où il avait été levé sur
wii un court répit donc pour pour les
élèves au total ce sont 61 départements
qui applique cette mesure là où le
nombre de contaminations dépasse le
seuil d alerte c'est le cas également
dans 1 54 dans quatre des territoires
ultramarins
on va retrouver notre reporter david
khalifa devant le ministère de
l'éducation nationale
[Musique]
david bonjour alors que va-t-il se
passer pour les élèves concernés passant
au niveau 2 du protocole sanitaire dans
les écoles primaires
et bien olivier il faudra à prévoir le
masque pour 61 départements concernés
pour rappel les mesures sanitaires des
établissements scolaires sont classés en
4 niveaux niveau 1 verge au niveau 2
orange niveau 3 et rouge elle niveau iv
c'est le ministère de l'éducation
nationale qui décide de passer à un
échelon un autre en fonction de la
circulation du virus dans chaque
département dès ce matin le protocole
sanitaire niveau 2 est appliquée dans
les territoires où le taux d'incidence
est supérieure à 50 pour cent mille
habitants sur plus de cinq jours écoutez
gabriela talent le porte parole du
gouvernement
partir de la semaine prochaine et de la
rentrée scolaire dans les départements
où le taux d'incidence c'est
malheureusement re stabiliser au dessus
de 50 pour cent mille habitants le
protocole scolaire va repasser du niveau
1 au niveau 2 c'est à dire que le masque
va à nouveau être rendu obligatoire pour
les enfants des écoles concernées ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que cela
concerne pour lundi prochain 39
départements 39 plus un puisque la
réunion a été ajouté à cette liste à
savoir que la guyane reste au niveau 4
cette prise de position de la part de
l'exécutif témoins d'une reprise
épidémique non négligeable et il se
pourrait que ce protocole s'applique à
l'ensemble du territoire d'ici les
prochaines semaines en tout cas selon
plusieurs l épidémiologiste et david à
part le port du masque obligatoire quels
sont les autres mesures de niveau 2 en
vigueur
à ce palier magali plusieurs mesures
sont mises en place pour limiter la
circulation du virus les élèves
continuent d'être accueillis en
présentiel à l'école mais par exemple
les activités physiques et sportives
devront se dérouler en principe à
l'extérieur si le sport en extérieur
n'est pas possible il est tout de même
autorisé de le pratiquer en intérieur
c'est ce qu'on peut lire sur le site du
ministère de l'éducation nationale en
revanche les sports de contact eux sont
interdits autre point le brassage entre
élèves de différents groupes c'est à
dire le brassage et des élèves de
différentes classes ne sont pas
autorisés même pour la restauration la
distanciation physique entre enfants
ados aussi être appliqué la désinfection
des bâtiments et surface et réalisé
plusieurs fois par jour et pour le
déjeuner le ministère l'éducation
nationale recommande d'organiser un
service individuel vous imaginez encore
une fois l'organisation qui que cela va
engendrer certains syndicats sont
d'ailleurs sceptique concernant son
retour en arrière écouter le retour du
port du masque va être compliqué parce
que ça va créer de l'incompréhension
chez les élèves et chez les parents ces
allers-retours risque de créer de
l'instabilité et de l'insécurité dans
les écoles
vous l'aurez compris ce protocole
applicable dès ce matin pose question
hormis les écoles doutre veut on devrait
être prise emmanuel macron les précisera
à demain soir avec l'ombre d'une
troisième dose obligatoire pour les
personnes les plus âgées et les plus
fragiles si la vie de pour ces
précisions david kelly fin en direct
devant le ministère de l'éducation
nationale à paris